and none about the vaccines and the
treatments we have today
so there was no option but to use
government regulations to protect our
nhs and save lives
but those restrictions on our liberties
have brought grave costs to our economy
our society and the chances of our
children
so from the outset we were clear that we
must chart a course back towards
normality as rapidly as possible by
developing the vaccines and treatments
that could gradually replace those
restrictions
and as a result of possibly the greatest
national effort in our peacetime history
that is exactly what we have done
thanks to our brilliant scientists
thanks to the extraordinary men and
women of our nhs
and to every one of you who has come
forward to get jabbed and get boosted
the united kingdom has become the first
country in the world to administer an
approved vaccine
and the fastest major european nation
to roll out both the vaccines and the
booster to half our population
we've emerged from the teeth of the
pandemic before many others retaining
one of the most open economies and
societies in europe the fastest growth
in the g7 last year
and while the pandemic is not over we
have passed the peak of the omicron wave
with cases falling and hospitalizations
in england now fewer than 10 000 and
still falling
and so now
we have the chance to complete that
transition back towards normality while
maintaining the contingencies to respond
to a resurgence or a new variant
as we have done throughout the past two
years we'll continue to work with the
devolved administrations as they decide
how to take forward their own plans
in england we will remove all remaining
domestic restrictions in law
from this thursday it will no longer be
law to self-isolate if you test positive
and so we will also end the provision of
self-isolation support payments although
statutory sick pay can still be claimed
for a further month
if you're a fully vaccinated close
contact or under 18 you will no longer
be asked to test daily for seven days
and if you're a close contact who is not
fully vaccinated you will no longer be
required to self-isolate
until april the first we will still
advise you to stay at home if you test
positive but after that we will
encourage people with covid with copic
symptoms to exercise personal
responsibility just as we encourage
people who may have flu to be
considerate towards others
it's only because levels of immunity are
so high and deaths are now if anything
below where you would normally expect
for this time of year that we can lift
these restrictions
and it's only because we know
omicron is less severe
that testing for omicron on the colossal
scale that we have been doing
is now much less valuable in pre in
preventing serious illness
we should be proud that the uk
established the biggest testing program
per person of any large country in the
world
but its budget
in the last financial year was bigger
than that of the home office and it cost
the testing program cost 2 billion
pounds just
last month alone
so we must scale back and prioritize our
resources for the most vulnerable
from today staff and students in most
education and child care settings will
no longer be asked to undertake twice
weekly asymptomatic testing
and from the first of april we will end
free symptomatic and asymptomatic
testing for the general public but we
will continue providing free symptomatic
tests to those of the highest risk from
cobit and
in line with the practice of many other
countries we're working with retailers
to ensure you will always be able to buy
a test
we should be clear
the pandemic
is not
over
and there may be significant resurgences
our scientists are certain that there
will be new variants and it is very
possible that those will be worse than
omicron
so we will continue to protect the most
vulnerable with targeted vaccinations
and treatments and we've bought enough
doses of vaccine to anticipate a wide
range of possible jcvi recommendations
today this includes a new spring booster
which will be offered to those age 75
and over older care home residents and
those over 12 who are immunosuppressed
we will also retain disease surveillance
systems and contingency measures which
can ensure our resilience in the face of
future waves or new variants
and we will build on the innovations
that defined the very best of our
response to the pandemic including
continuing the work of the vaccines task
force which has already secured
contracts with manufacturers trialling
new vaccines which could provide
protection against new variants
today is not the day we can declare
victory over kovid because this virus is
not
going away but
it is the day when all the efforts of
the last two years
finally enabled us to protect ourselves
whilst restoring our liberties
in full
and after two of the darkest grimmest
years in our peacetime history i do
believe this is a moment of pride for
our nation and a source of hope for all
that we can achieve in the years to come